si et d'être venu cet après midi pour
répondre aux questions de la commission
des lois et de la commission de la
culture qui ont besoin d'éclairage et
d'information précis sur ce qui s'est
réellement déroulé lors de cette finale
du stade de france au stade de france
cette finale au stade de france ça a été
aurait dû être
l'occasion de d'expériences vécues
heureuse et je pense en particulier au
match de football que qui était qui
donnait l'occasion de voir deux des plus
belles les équipes européennes le
liverpool football club et le real de
madrid
qui s'affrontaient dans cette finale
dans notre stade de france
malheureusement ça n'a pas été que ça il
ya eu d'autres expériences vécues
l'expérience vécue par les supporters
qui n'ont pas pu accéder au stade et qui
avec billets sans billet ou avec des
faux billets
seront connus des scènes qu'il n'aurait
pas dû voir l'expérience aussi des
personnes qui ont subi des préjudices
voire des violences que ce soit à
proximité du stade ou dans les
transports en commun ces
dysfonctionnements ont été vues par des
millions de spectateurs alors même que
nous le savons tous la france s'apprête
à accueillir un des plus grands moments
sportifs que sont les jeux olympiques
dans deux ans évidemment la commission
des lois et son président monsieur
françois noël buffet et la commission de
la culture que je préside nous
souhaitions comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et en tirer tous les enseignements
la fédération française de football et
organisateur avec l'uefa vous nous
précisera évidemment dans quels termes
et selon quelles modalités de cet
événement nous voudrions connaître
précisément les informations dont vous
disposiez concernant l'organisation de
ce match en terme de sécurité publique
et d'ordre public est-ce que les risques
possibles liés à des problèmes de
sécurité d'ordre public il lié aux
grèves du rer ont été suffisamment
anticipé et nous aimerions vous entendre
sur ce point notamment ce qui s'est dit
ou ce qui ne s'est pas dit dans les
réunions de de préparation entre les
différents acteurs comment s'est passée
cette coordination entre ces acteurs et
puis de manière plus générale quel est
votre interprétation du déroulement de
cette soirée une des difficultés que
nous avons nous analyser les choses
c'est de savoir exactement qui décide de
quoi et qui fait quoi dans cette
organisation qui est somme toute un peu
complexe sans parler de se renvoyer la
balle l'expression n'est pas forcément
heureuse dans la matière mais je
voudrais juste citer là une phrase du
ministre de l'intérieur de la semaine
dernière elle a lors de son audition la
semaine dernière madame la ministre des
sports et moi-même n'organisant pas les
matchs de football en france nous ne
tenons pas la billetterie nous
n'embauchons pas les stadiers nous ne
contrôlons pas les billets et nous ne
touchons pas l'argent qui va avec la
responsabilité et donc à tout le moins
partagés dans cette affaire c'est bien
ce partage de responsabilités que nous
aimerions analyser avec vous est ce que
vous êtes
responsable vous aussi ou co responsable
des difficultés et des
dysfonctionnements qui ont lieu quelle
est votre part de responsabilités
quelles sont les erreurs qu'avec le
recul quasiment quinze jours après vous
analysez bref autant de sujets que nous
améliorions
discuter et voir avec vous ce que je
vous propose le président du fai on est
d'accord c'est de vous laisser la parole
pour vous avez préparé quelques
transparent n'ayant conditions n'aident
pas trop long pour que nous puissions
vous poser des questions c'est un quart
d'heure maximum pour le problème propos
liminaires et puis ensuite les
sénatrices et sénateurs présents
physiquement ou derrière leur écran vous
poseront des questions ce président ça
vous convient
deux présidents
messieurs les présidents mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
en premier lieu je tiens à remercier le
sénat de nous avoir invités à cette
audition
elle nous donne l'occasion et
l'opportunité de fournir nos éléments
objectifs
d'appréciation sur les incidents qui ont
lieu lors de la finale de la ligue des
champions le 28 mai dernier à paris
il est important effectivement pour la
première fédération sportive française
de pouvoir faire valoir sa vision sur
des incidents en toute transparence
avec les informations qui sont à notre
disposition
dans la sphère d'action qui était la
nôtre
cela étant dit je voudrais commencer le
propos liminaire
justement en ayant
en exprimant à regret très sincère au
nom de la fédération française de
football sur les graves incidents qui se
sont déroulés au stade de france le 28
mai
je veux ensuite dire aux fans de
liverpool
du real madrid qui étaient venus en
grand nombre
supporter pacifiquement leur équipe que
les incidents auxquels ils ont été
confrontés sont déplorables et que nous
condamnons avec la plus extrême fermeté
les actes qui ont été commis par des
individus qui se sont comportés comme
des délinquants est donc désormais le
sort relève de la justice
le football est un jeu
assister à un match est un plaisir et il
doit le rester
vous le savez c'est en raison de la
guerre en ukraine que l'uefa a décidé
d'exclure les cubes les clubs russes des
compétitions et des de localiser la
finale de la ligue des champions qui
était initialement prévu à saint
pétersbourg
lorsqu'il s'est agi de trouver une
nouvelle localisation pour relocaliser
la finale de la ligue des champions
l'uefa par une décision du 25 février a
choisi la france et le stade de france
dans l'urgence qui était la sienne
l'uefa a considéré que la france et la
fédération française de football donnait
les garanties nécessaires dans leur
capacité à accueillir un événement d'une
telle ampleur
et donc je veux aussi rappeler ici que
depuis l'inauguration du stade de france
en janvier
1998 la fédération française de football
a organisé très régulièrement à guichet
fermé donc avec plus de 75000 personnes
des matches
ces rencontres se sont déroulées
dans des conditions optimales de
sécurité pour les acteurs du jeu comme
pour les spectateurs
en 24 ans
nous ne déplorons uniquement que deux
très graves incidents
en 2001 l'envahissement du terrain à
l'occasion du match france algérie
et bien sûr le 13 novembre 2015 lors du
match france allemagne où le stade de
france a été le théâtre d'une attaque
terroriste causant la mort d'une
personne et en blessant 56 autres
je voudrais aussi rappeler qu'à cette
occasion
dans ces circonstances
extrêmes dramatique
l'action concertée des services de
l'état du stade de france et de la
fédération française de football ont
permis d'éviter un bilan plus lourd et
pire
en matière de rang de grande rencontre
qui rassemble plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de spectateurs
nous sommes nés de vis ni des amateurs
l'organisation de l'euro 2016
de la coupe du monde féminine en 2019
sont d'autres exemples du savoir faire
français en matière d'accueil des
grandes compétitions
plus récemment la finale de la coupe de
france le 8 mai dernier pour un match
qui était pourtant classé par la
préfecture de police à un niveau de
risque 4 sur une échelle de 5 cd
parfaitement déroulée
encore dernièrement le 3 juin la
fédération a accueillis dans de
parfaites conditions de sécurité près de
80000 personnes pour le match france
danemark
c'est donc avec la conviction
de notre capacité à faire que nous avons
accueilli la décision de l'uefa de
confier à la france l'organisation de
cette finale de ligue des champions
si la fierté et l'enthousiasmé télé
sentiment dominant nous avions aussi
conscience du défi qui était le nôtre
la finale de la ligue des champions et
le plus grand match de clubs dans le
monde
elle suscite un intérêt planétaire qui
conduit plus de 300 millions de
personnes à regarder le match à la
télévision
quant aux spectateurs
nous avons reçu plus d'un million de
demandes de billets pour un stade de
75000 place
pour faire face à cet engouement et pour
respecter le cahier des charges de
l'uefa
il faut habituellement 18 mois de
préparation pour un tel match
nous en avons eu trois ce qui vous
concerne vous conviendrez est un délai
particulièrement court
pourtant
sans la grève du rer b
la multiplication de faux billets et les
comportements délictueux
nous aurions relever ce défi
j'en veux pour preuve que les deux fans
zone celle du cours de vincennes et
celle de saint denis qui ont accueilli
conduire nous avons organisé en moins de
10 jours ont accueilli plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de supporters sans
que nous n'ayons a constaté ni
difficulté particulière d'organisation
ni à déplorer d'incident majeur
pour autant
nous ne serions pas devant vous cet
après midi si tout s'était déroulé comme
nous l'espérions
madame la directrice générale de la
fédération et monsieur le directeur des
compétitions
vont détailler à ma suite les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place par
la fédération française de football dans
son champ de compétence
ils mettront aussi en lumière les
dysfonctionnements qui ont pu se
produire
et formuleront des premières
recommandations tirées de l'expérience
de ces tristes événements
pour conclure avant de laisser la parole
aux autres membres de notre délégation
je voudrais souligner que la finale de
la ligue des champions constitue à nos
yeux une très regrettable exceptions
dont nous tirerons les enseignements
pour encore nous améliorer
afin de continuer dans le futur à
accueillir des finales des tournois
finaux de grandes communes de
compétition comme nous avons su le faire
avec succès dans le passé
merci infiniment
messieurs les présidents mesdames
messieurs je souhaite également appuyé
les propos de notre vice président
philippe diallo au nom de la fédération
française de football nous regrettons
sincèrement les graves incidents qui ont
eu lieu au stade de france le 28 mai
dernier
nous ressentons un sentiment mêlé de
tristesse de colère et d'indignation
tout le monde attendait cette finale
cette finale aurait dû être la fête du
football européen mais elle a été gâchée
nous devons tous ensemble tirer des
enseignements de ce qu'il s'est passé
pour que cela ne se reproduise plus
comme nous l'a expliqué notre vice
président philippe diallo il nous
expliquer comment la france a été
choisie ce qu'il faut savoir quand il ya
une telle organisation qui est mise en
place c'est que l'organisme l'uefa fait
toujours appel pour l'organisation de
ces finales de coupe d'europe au pays et
aux fédérations haute pour les aider
dans leur préparation d'où l'implication
de la fff dans plusieurs domaines pour
cette finale toujours sous le contrôle
et la validation de l'uefa alors
précisément en quoi consistaient les
missions de la fédération française de
football pour rappel on vous a mis les
différentes missions on va commencer par
les missions du stade de france c'est
bien évidemment la mise à disposition du
stade la sécurité incendie de
l'événement et l'accompagnement dans les
bras dans l'élaboration et la validation
des dossiers de sécurité un bon
dispositif un bon fonctionnement des
dispositifs de contrôle d'accès et la
restauration grand public l'uefa sa
première mission c'est la
commercialisation de la billetterie et d
hospitalité la livraison de la rencontre
sportive les contreparties des
partenaires télémarketing l'animation
les animations sur le parvis et dans
l'arène la signalétique directionnelle à
l'intérieur et aux abords du stade de
france et l'habillage de l'enceinte
quant à nous la fédération notre
première mission c'est la sécurité
privée c'est à dire la mise en place du
dispositif de stadiers et d'agent
d'accueil au point de près filtrage aux
portes du stade et à l'intérieur du
stade le plan d'acheminement des
spectateurs qu'ils viennent des gares
des rer des métros et d'un certain don
trompe et de et des fans zone le
recrutement à la gestion des volontaires
la relation avec les villes hôtes et le
gouvernement pour rappel
on vous a mis la préfecture de police
évidemment la sécurité publique et les
villes hôtes avec l'animation dans les
villes de paris et de saint denis
la fff a analysé quatre types de
difficultés qui ont conduit à cette
situation
lors de la soirée du 28 mai
difficultés essentiellement situées à
l'extérieur du stade ces incidents ont
été aggravés par une accumulation est
une succession de dysfonctionnements que
je vais vous décrire la première
difficulté
l'arrivée aux abords du stade d'un grand
nombre de spectateurs supérieure à la
capacité du stade et la présence de faux
billets voici les chiffres dont on
dispose il y a eu sur ses 110 mille
personnes qui ont été acheminés au stade
de france
6200 personnes qui sont arrivées jusqu'à
la station stade de france par le rer b
source ratp par une personne le soir du
match il y a eu également 36000
personnes qui sont arrivées par le rer d
à la station stade de france source ratp
le soir du match il y a eu également 37
mille personnes qui sont arrivés à la
station stade de france par la ligne 13
source ratp le stade du mal le soir du
match il y a eu également des autocars
il y avait un grand nombre d'autocars
puisqu'il ya eu 450 car qui ont
transporté 20 1905 personnes source fff
il y a eu également des taxis il y a eu
six mille six cent quatre-vingts
personnes source préfecture de police
sans oublier les véhicules légers où il
y a eu quatre mille cent onze personnes
ce qui représente bien un total de 110
mille personnes versus une capacité du
stade de 35000 donc ses 110 mille
personnes vous le verrez quand on vous
montrera les plans tout à l'heure était
aux pardons de 35 me
oui il ya eu souihli auparavant la
capacité du stade c'était 75000
personnes et il y a eu cent dix mille
personnes qui ont été acheminés aux
abords du stade de france on vous
montrera sur un plan tout à l'heure le
vous montrera sur un plan pour que vous
puissiez visualiser
et en fait toutes ces personnes
supplémentaires ont créé une situation
inédite qui a créé une pression et un
engorgement sur les dispositifs de
contrôle en pré filtrage est aux portes
du stade
la commercialisation de la billetterie
l'ensemble des billets commercialisé par
l'uefa étaient prévus initialement sous
forme électronique avec un système de
blog shane donc non falsifiable
cependant à la demande des clubs
liverpool a obtenu la totalité de ces
tickets au format papier soit vingt
mille tickets le real de madrid a eu six
mille tickets au format papier
la ville de saint-denis 600 tickets en
format papier et enfin la ville de paris
280 ticket au format papier
pourquoi c'est important cette
information ces tickets papier ont
facilité et permis la fabrication de
faux billets
2536 faux billets ont été scannées au
tripode du stade avec un résultat
inconnu quand on dit un résultat
inconnue c'est qu'il ya un code barre
qui étaient générés et qui est donc
frauduleux on vous a mis comme chiffres
parce que pour que vous puissiez vous
rendre compte sur des grands événements
et notamment sur des concerts
internationaux il y a en moyenne jusqu'à
300 faux billets donc vous pouvez déjà
mesuré que aujourd'hui
2471 faux billets est un nombre très
élevé
sur ses 2471 faux billets scanner entre
18h et 21h 35 cela représente en moyenne
57 faux billets scanner toutes les cinq
minutes
66% de ses billets
1644 ont été scannées uniquement sur
trois portes les portes x y et z dans le
secteur sud dédié aux supporters de
liverpool
autre information sur ces trois portes
ces fameuses trois portes x y et z qui
permettent de faire rentrer 15000
personnes un billet sur dix étaient faux
tous ces faux billets ont eu pour
conséquence d'engorger fortement les
portes
il est toutefois très difficile
aujourd'hui d'évaluer le nombre de faux
billets au total parce qu'elle sait
2471 faux billets il faut ajouter tous
les faux billets qui ont été pris au
niveau des prêts filtrage tous les faux
billets qui ont pu être pris dans les
fan zone et certaines personnes qui ont
pu rentrer dans le stade sans oublier
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez il y à
une enquête de police qui est en cours
on sait qui est à la fan zone de
vincennes il y à une personne qui a été
prise avec un sac de 50 faux billets et
on a récupéré déjà à peu près 250 faux
billets auprès filtrage voilà les
chiffres dont on dispose aujourd'hui
chiffres que qui sont tracés puisqu'ils
ont été les 2471 scanner au niveau des
portes du stade de france
la deuxième difficulté la gestion des
flux de spectateurs venant des
transports en commun le mouvement de la
grève de la ratp sur leur herbe et a
conduit à reporter une très grande
partie des spectateurs sur le rer d
occasionnant des congestions très
significative entre la sortie du rer d
et la zone du pré filtrage qui est très
étroite à cet endroit pour information
au niveau de la zone de près filtrage du
rer b il y a dix couloirs de palpation
alors qu un rer b où la zone est
beaucoup plus large il y a vingt
couloirs de palpation
c'est congestion bien entendu était
aggravée par l'afflux de personnes non
munies de billets ou munis de faux
billets à titre d'exemple le rer d a vu
transiter 36000 personnes au lieu de 10
à 15000 personnes habituellement alors
que la ligne b n'a été utilisé que par
six mille personnes au lieu de trente
mille personnes habituellement ce qui
est logique puisque comme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure il y a vingt couloirs de
palpation au niveau du rer b
ce départ massif s'est aggravée dès la
fin de l'après-midi du 28 mai par des
messages en gare indiquant de ne pas
utiliser la ligne b mais la ligne d pour
se rendre au stade alors que 4 trains
sur 5 fonctionnait normalement
cette situation a essentiellement
concerné les supporters de liverpool je
vous rappelle les supporters de
liverpool ils sont situés au sud et ils
viennent via le rer d puisque à 21h
heure du coup d'envoi théorique seuls
63% d'entre eux étaient assis en tribune
en revanche les supporters de madrid qui
venait par la ligne 13 ils étaient eux à
99% à 6 à leur siège à 21h
la troisième difficulté rencontre et la
vérification des billets au point de
près filtrage par les agents de sécurité
et le positionnement des forces de
l'ordre en soutien de ces derniers
la fff a proposé un dispositif de 1680
agents de sécurité privés le soir de la
finale de la coupe de la ligue des
champions au lieu de 1400 pour la finale
de la coupe de france le 8 mai dernier
un masque un match classé à risques
niveau 4 sur une échelle de 5 soit 17 %
de personnes en plus comme à chaque
match ce dispositif est validée par la
préfecture de police
parmi ces six parmi ces 1680 agents 258
étaient répartis au point de près
filtrage et avait deux missions deux
missions distinctes la première c'est la
palpation conformément au plan
vigipirate
la deuxième c'est la vérification de la
validité des titres d'accès soit via un
stylo chimiques pour les billets papier
et via une carte électronique qui acquit
activer le qr code du billet sur
téléphone nous n'avons connu aucun
problème de fiabilité
quand on a passé ses stylos sur les
tickets
cette double tâche demandé aux agents de
sécurité au niveau du prêt filtrage
ajoutée aux flux massif de personnes à
certains endroits les ont mis en
difficulté à tel point que le prêt
filtrage au niveau du rer d a été
relâché pendant 15 minutes pour éviter d
écrasement de personnes quand on dit
relâché c'est à dire qu'il y avait plus
de contrôler tout le monde pouvait
pénétrer sur le parvis aux abords du
stade
les agents de sécurité aussi nombreux
efforts mais soit ils ne peuvent pas
contenir une telle pression de la foule
sans être assisté par les forces de
l'ordre
c'est pourquoi un dispositif
complémentaire a été mis en place par la
préfecture de police comme sur la finale
de la coupe de france cependant les
forces de l'ordre placé en majorité
derrière les stadiers n'ont pas eu la
possibilité d'agir efficacement
la quatrième grande difficultés
rencontrées les agressions et les
intrusions de très nombreux délinquants
ont profité de cette finale pour se
rendre au stade de france dans le seul
but de pénétrer dans le stade sans
billet de volée et d'agresser les
supporters des deux clubs présents aux
alentours du stade
nous n'avions jamais vu ça on a tous vu
des images à la télévision sur les
réseaux sociaux des témoignages des
témoignages de salariés de la fédération
française qui je cite ont eu leur peur
de la vie nos collègues de l'uefa qui
avait le centre d'accréditation qui
était placé juste à côté du stade de
france et qui se sont fait envahir par
des délinquants à tel point qu'ils ont
dû s'enfermer dans leur bureau et sont
restés pendant quatre heures bloqué
centre d'accréditation pourquoi de
telles personnes sont venues tout
simplement pour voler des accréditations
afin de rentrer dans le stade
la présence très importante de ces
délinquants a obligé les forces de
l'ordre à intervenir à de très
nombreuses reprises
mais cela les a détournés de leur
mission de sécurisation des points de
près filtrage et des accès aux portes du
stade ces actes inacceptables ont
contribué à créer des engorgements de
flux de personnes aux portes du stade et
ont semé la peur parmi les spectateurs
après avoir apporté notre vision sur
l'ensemble des dysfonctionnements qui
ont entraîné cette situation je vais
passer maintenant la parole à notre
directeur des relations internationales
et des compétitions internationales qui
va vous présenter en détail les actions
et opérations relevant de la fff
merci france messieurs les présidents
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme l'on dit philippe et comme l'on
dit philippe et florence ces événements
sont regrettables on a préparé du mieux
que l'on pouvait dans le dellec était
imparti et ses trois mois qui nous ont
amenés jusqu'à la finale du 28 mai ont
été l'occasion de très nombreuses
réunions avec le préfet cadot et ses
équipes de la djs avec le préfet de
police de paris avec le préfet du
département du 93 et l'ensemble des
acteurs et on a fait tout ce que l'on
pouvait tout ce qu'on avait en
conséquence pour organiser cette
manifestation maintenant que c'est fait
il faut en tirer les enseignements et se
dire
comment collectivement on doit
progresser pour faire que de tels
événements à l'horizon d'une coupe du
monde de rugby de jeux olympiques ne se
reproduise pas et que les gens qui sont
en responsabilité sur ces deux
événements majeurs internationaux et
l'ensemble des éléments et ce qu'on
appelle noir et ex pour faire qu'ils
organisent au mieux l'accueil des
spectateurs et des différentes
populations invitées le prochain la
première recommandation que l'on formule
au nom de la fédération française de
football elle est en lien avec le plan
de mobilité on insiste sur le fait qu'il
faut définir conjointement le plan de
mobilité on insiste sur le fait qu'il
faut avoir une communication en temps
réel sur les flux des personnes qui
viennent au stade de france entre
l'organisateur que nous sommes la
fédération française de football la
préfecture de police et des opérateurs
des transports publics pour ce faire je
vais vous prendre l'exemple de ce que
nous avons fait de ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné
dans le cadre de la finale de la
champion's league nous avons organisé
fédération française de football et ufa
ce qu'on appelle un plan de mobilité qui
concerne un dispositif d'accueil et
d'orientation ça veut dire que
précisément nous avons pris en compte
l'ensemble des spectateurs venant des
différents clubs finalistes liverpool et
du real de madrid sur leur acheminement
et à partir du moment où il posait le
pied sur le sol français nous avons fait
en sorte de les acheminer sur les
différents lieux où ils pouvaient être
amenés à se re à se reconstituer que ce
soit le stade de france avec la partie
autocar nous avons défini avec l'aide du
stade de france la ville de saint denis
et plaine commune un dispositif
d'accueil pour séparer ces personnes
schématiquement la partie nord du stade
de france était dédiée aux supporters de
madrid la partie sud aux supporters de
liverpool et aux populations invitées de
l'uefa et des différents partenaires de
la compétition ce plan nous l'avons
travaillé pendant trois mois sous
l'égide de la préfecture du 93 qui nous
a fortement accompagné pour le mettre en
oeuvre une fois que nous avons fait ce
plan là nous avons également défini
l'accueil et l'orientation des personnes
qui viendra travers les aéroports nous
avions trois aéroports principaux
l'aéroport de beauvais est sous le
contrôle des aéroports de paris
l'aéroport de charles de gaulle à
l'aéroport d'orly qu'est ce que nous
avons fait nous avons travaillé sur les
flux considérant quoi je vais prendre
l'exemple des supporters de liverpool 3
typologies de supporters de liverpool je
suis supporter de liverpool avec un
billet je veux me rendre au stade de
france appartement vous est pris en
compte sur les aéroports nous avons
défini un plan d'acheminement nous avons
contractualisé avec les différents
opérateurs que son aéroport de paris
l'aéroport de beauvais ratp sncf sur un
dispositif d'accueil et d'orientation
appartement il arrivait dans les
aéroports et dans les gares
puis nous sommes allés jusqu alors faire
des plans pour leur expliquer comment
cheminée toujours avec la contrainte que
nous avions très forte était de les
différencier les flux de faire en sorte
que les supporters de liverpool ne
croise jamais les supporters de madrid
mais également considérant la capacité
d'emport du rer b par rapport au rrd et
du nombre de flux et des couloirs de
palpation tel et tel qu'expliqué par
florence pour les inciter à s'orienter
majoritairement vers le vers le rer b
vous avez là le détail du dispositif que
nous avons mis en place sur ses discours
ses différentes opérations
appartement ou laisser les supporters
sont arrivés et ont rejoint paris nous
avons également travaillé comme je
disais avec la ratp et la sncf sur des
annonces dans les stations en anglais et
en français pour les inciter je suis
supporter de liverpool je n'ai pas de
billets mais je veux me rendre à la fan
zone quel que soit l'endroit où vous
étiez dans paris dans une station de
métro dans un lieu de divertissement
vous aviez les et des informations sur
comment vous rendre à la fan zone je
suis supporter de liverpool léger un
billet je veux me rendre au stade de
france même principe je suis supporter
de madrid également et nous avons fait
en sorte d'avoir un maillage dans la
plupart des stations dans paris pour
pouvoir avoir ce réflexe là et leur
permettre de s'orienter facilement que
ce soit à travers des messages sonores à
travers des hôtes et hôtesses qui les
guidaient mais également des plans
pourquoi j'insiste sur l'autisme sur la
communication en temps réel à partir du
moment où il a été pris la décision de
réorienter les flux
il aurait dû nous aurions dû avoir
l'information en temps réel pour pouvoir
faire preuve d'agilité nous c'est le
stade de france qui nous a accompagné la
fédération française de football qui
prend en compte l'accueil des
spectateurs la préfecture de police qui
nous est sur l'orientation mais
également la ratp et la sncf pour
orienter ces flux
d'un point de vue très simple
appartement on nous dit on use or nous
aurions une information que le flux du
rer d et est poussé vers le pardon le
flux du rer b était poussé vers le flux
du rrd en milieu d'après midi nous
aurions dû nous aurions pu avoir le
temps de repenser nos dispositifs à
savoir avec l'accord de la des opc faire
évoluer les forces les forces mobiles
pour couper le flux de la circulation
qui arrive du rer b vers le rer b mais
également pour repenser notre motifs
d'accueil sur les couloirs de palpation
et séance à l'enseignement pour nous qui
est important on a beau construire des
dispositifs pour accueillir les
spectateurs pour les acheminer dans les
meilleures conditions dans les andes
différents endroits où ils veulent
profiter de la finale de la champion's
league avec ou sans but il ya un moment
où si certaines personnes prennent des
décisions sans en référer aux autres
partis ça ne fonctionne pas c'est à dire
si vous pouvez préciser ce que voulait
dire à travers cette phrase qui nous
n'avions pas y lire nous n'avons pas eu
l'information que le flux du rer avait
été déviée ratp la préfecture de police
ne vous a pas prévenu que la préfecture
de police non plus n'avaient pas
l'information
hier que nous avons nous nous sommes
retrouvés nous nous sommes retrouvés aux
alentours de 18h30 à voir un afflux
massif de supporters en provenance du
rer d là où le dispositif que nous
avions mis en oeuvre permettait un
accueil maximum des supporters sur la
ligne rer b la ratp ne vous a pas
prévenu exactement
et nous sommes pour terminer sur mon
propos nous sommes allés jusqu'à la
signalétique du dernier kilomètre alors
nous avons entendu certaines personnes
s'exprimer disant qu'il n'y avait aucune
cinétique aux abords du stade de france
c'est évidemment complètement faux avec
l'uefa nous avons également balisé le
dernier kilomètre prévoyant un
dispositif pour orienter les spectateurs
en fonction de leur arrivée ligne 13 rer
b ou rer d nous sommes même jusqu'à les
prévoir un dispositif comme vous pouvez
le voir en haut à droite permettant aux
supporters arrivant du rer d
s'il y avait un engorgement de cheminer
vers l'arrivée du rer b et l avenue la
plus large pour accéder au stade de
france et aux couleurs de palpation
c'était là ce qu'on voulait partager
avec vous sur ce sur ce retour
d'expérience le deuxième enseignement
que nous voulons partager avec vous
c'est la coordination
et organiser un événement ses
coordonnées des parties prenantes
évidemment et c'est notre métier mais
organiser une finale de championnat si
c'est un événement à part vous avez là
un plan qui vous matérialise la prise en
compte du stade de france
organiser un évènement comme la fina 206
n'est pas uniquement prendre en compte
le stade de france et séduit porte
d'accès c'est prendre en compte
l'ensemble des flux piétons l'ensemble
des flux véhicules autocar mais
également transports en commun qui
accède au stade de france et pour ça ce
que nous recommandons vivement c'est que
dans le futur nous coordonnions et nous
construisions avec la préfecture de
police de paris le dispositif d'accueil
et de sécurité de l'événement il faut
comprendre c'est que vous avez sur un
événement comme celui là soixante quinze
mille personnes acheminées notre métier
nous stade de france et de les prendre
en compte au prince près filtrage est
aux portes du stade de france
le métier de la ratp la sncf et nous
acheminer ses spectateurs
et le métier jusqu'à la compétence de la
démo pc c'est de nous aider à encadrer
ces personnes pour qu'elle accueille au
stade de france dans les meilleures
conditions de sécurité
samedi le 28 mai ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la ratp à travers la ligne b
et leur r&d pardon nous a envoyé un flux
de supporters ininterrompue et nous
n'avions pas l'information de cette
arrivée là le rer b où l'air rdc huit
trains par heure avec une capacité
d'emport qui va entre 1600 et 2000
personnes ça veut dire que par heure
vous pousser vers le stade de france
sans savoir comment ça réagit aux portes
comment nous arrivons nous à faire
rentrer ces personnes en nous assurant
qu'elles ont un titre d'accès valable en
nous assurant qu'elles respectent les
consignes du plan vigipirate en nous
assurant qu'elles sont les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit dans le stade
quand vous nous poussez entre 2600 et
vingt mille personnes par heure la chose
devient extrêmement compliqué quand vous
rencontrez des difficultés d'engorgement
et c'est là le deuxième enseignement que
nous poussons auprès de vous c'est de
faire en sorte que demain nous
construisons nos dispositifs pour que
les forces de sécurité privées leur
emplacement leur positionnement soit en
adéquation avec les forces de sécurité
publique le meilleur exemple c'est le
dernier france danemark quelques les
voeux tel que l'évoqué philippe diallo
notre vice président ça a parfaitement
fonctionné parce que nous ne sommes
parfaitement coordonnés entre ce qui
était de la responsabilité de
l'organisateur la fédération française
de football et comment la démo pc nous a
accompagnés pour prendre en compte
l'ensemble des supporters pour les
permettre d'accéder au stade de france
dans les meilleures conditions
le troisième enseignement que nous
voulons partager avec vous c'est la
billetterie dématérialisée nous n'allons
pas nous à bord nous parler très
longtemps de ce sujet il est simple la
finale de championnat civil à
matérialiser un billet papier est
falsifiable l'enquète qui est menée
aujourd'hui poker nous avons été
auditionnés jeudi dernier pour lequel
l'uefa va être prochainement auditionné
par la brigade de répression de la
délinquance astucieuse
est en train de prouver que la fraude
était massive organisée par des
imprimeurs professionnels et léché les
et les éléments sont en train de
remonter c'est à l'issue cette enquête
que nous connaîtrons le nombre de faux
billets qui ont été dupliqués imprimer
la certitude que nous avons c'est qu'il
n'y a eu aucun billet e-billet tel que
vous l'avez là qui n'a pu être falsifiés
et donc ce que nous recommandons
vivement c'est que pour les prochains
événements avec l'accord du gouvernement
l'accueil de ces événements ne se
fassent qu'à la stricte et unique
condition qu' aucun billet ne puisse
être en version papier ça vous ça vous
évitera un nombre conséquent de fraude
de faux billets et ça fuit l'irak
fluidifiera les accès au stade de france
merci avant de donner la parole aux
collègues
votre dernière aux derniers propos
attire mon attention sur le fait que je
comprends parfaitement en revanche
pourquoi attend accepté alors que ce
n'était pas la règle pour ce type de
compétition le fait d'avoir pour le club
de liverpool des billets papier
parce que si nous n'avons pas de billet
papier
on se rend compte que notamment les
supporters madrilènes ont accédé sans
trop de difficultés au stade donc
pourquoi avoir accepté cette possibilité
de billets papier sachant que les
risques de falsification sont réels
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question en disant nous aller tout à
l'heure de rappeler vue d'actes mans les
circonstances dans lesquelles la france
était candidate pour organiser
le match de football à paris très bien
tout en précisant qu'il faut
habituellement 18 mois pour préparer un
tel événement
peut-être de son ou 13 ans et pourquoi
18 mois
si nous avons une expérience assez
grande et nous l'avons cette expérience
est assez grande volontairement comme
français je me mets dedans
nous avons répondu positivement pour
l'organiser en trois mois et s'il est
donc sûr qu'on ne pouvait pas parce
qu'il faut habituellement des humains il
ya une question à quoi sont utiles ces
18 mois et qu'est ce qu'il a manqué dans
les trois mois qui était imparti pour
pouvoir
remplir la mission correctement c'est la
deuxième question la troisième question
vous avez en charge les stadiers et
notamment ceux qui vont accueillir les
gens il y en avait plus vous avez prévu
plus que d'habitude il n'y a pas de
difficultés là dessus pouvez vous nous
préciser la manière dont vous les
recruter la formation que vous le leur
donner et comment les choses se passent
pour être stadiers six mois demain je
vais de stadiers au stade de france
comment je fais et qui allez vous me
demandez
et puis je suis pas certain vous ne
preniez d'ailleurs mais on sait jamais
je n'aurais pas difficulté sur test
d'effort donc vraiment ça c'est une
troisième question voilà je m'en tiens à
cela pour l'instant il y en aura sans
doute d'autres au moins dans ce premier
point
alors s'il ya une autre une question
partagée oublier
une petite contradiction il me semble
noter une petite contradiction entre ce
que vous vous dites est ce que nous a
dit le préfet de police ce matin parce
que ce matin le préfet de police ne dit
que il s'est concentré sur le risque
terroriste
et c'est la manière dont ils ont abordé
la gestion de l'événement et puis
également sur le risque d'écrasement des
gens ont pour éviter tout problème
majeur on a bien compris les choses tout
en affirmant que du coup la sécurité en
tant que tel à l'égard de ceux qui se
comportaient vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président comme des délinquants ou qui
même ont eu des actes de délinquance
soit laissé un peu de côté disons les
choses telles qu'elles sont c'est parce
que le contrôle des collègues qui
étaient là ce matin pointu avoir bien
compris et vous même vous venez de dire
linverse là vous venez de dire
l'obligation pour les forces de l'ordre
d'intervenir pour les délinquants
étaient absolument
essentiel du moindre présence au stade
des filtres halde et des lieux de
filtrage
on a besoin de comprendre deux avis
différent deux positions différentes
pour des gens qui ont travaillé ensemble
pour organiser cet événement
s'est pas suffisamment clair merci
je verrai là sur la première le fait
qu'il y ait eu des des billets papier
comme je voulais dit tout à l'heure en
préambule
l'unique instance qui a la main sur la
commercialisation de la billetterie
c'est l'uefa donc au départ tout était
prévu pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir des billets électroniques
je veux dire à la demande ou à la forte
demande des clubs
l'uefa a autorisé le club de liverpool
est le club de du real madrid mais le
real madrid n'a utilisé que n'a demandé
que six mille tickets papier alors que
le club de liverpool a demandé la
totalité de ses billets en format papier
donc l'instance c'est factuel qui a
autorisé la délivrance et la possibilité
d'avoir des tickets en papier c'est
l'uefa puisque c'est l'uefa qui est
responsable de la commercialisation de
la billetterie
non non non mais je peux comprendre le
mécanisme suivez le mécanisme doit les
fêtes les madrilènes où les supporteurs
madrilènes avaient un billet papier pour
certains donc oui oui là il n'y a pas eu
de difficulté non en clair il ya pas eu
de fraude du de ce point de vue si si je
peux si ça peut compléter en ré imaginer
la demande de liverpool s'est elle pour
permettre de commercialiser les
vingt-deux mille billets à l'ensemble
des supporters et ils ont une habitude
de le faire en version papier
la demande de madrid c'était de répartir
les flux donc les 6000 papy le billet
papier pour c'était pour des clients
internes du club des partenaires les
sponsors les familles et les autres
billets c'était pour les supporters et
effectivement il n'y a eu aucune
falsification de billets côté madrid
[Musique]
je vais apporter les éléments de réponse
sur le votre deuxième question sur
pourquoi 18 mois versus trois mois
dix-huit mois c'est ce qu'on appelle
nous dans le métier c'est le eric weems
de l'uefa c'est à dire que quand pour
candidater pour organiser une finale de
championship vous candidatez trois
enfants avant la date de la finale et
vous répondez à un cahier des charges de
l'uefa ce cahier des charges prévoit
qu'à 18 mois de la manifestation quand
vous avez été choisi vous devez mettre
en place un comité d'organisation local
qui prend
l'organisation de cet événement en lien
avec tf1 et vous devez dans les huit
mois qui vont de 18 mois dix mois
proposer à l'uefa un cadre
d'organisation dans lequel vous faites
appel aux différentes parties prenantes
les parties prenantes d'une finale de
champion's league la première des
parties prenantes celle est à dire que
vous demandez un certain nombre de
lettres de garanties à l'état qui
concourent à la maison de la
manifestation apportant un certain
nombre d'éléments d'appréciation qui
permettent de garantir que vous
accueillerez la manifestation dans les
meilleures conditions telles que le
souhaitent l'uefa notamment des sujets
sur la facilité de des formes des
formulaires doute des formules et
douanières sur la facilité d'accueil
dans le public dans du septet adore la
capacité à mobiliser les transports et à
mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire qui concourent à la
manifestation quand et puis vous rentrez
dans la dernière année donc si vous
voulez répondre à votre question
monsieur le président effectivement ce
qui est comparable c'est un an
l'organisation dur versus les trois mois
que nous avons eues est ce que vous
voulez nous souligner c'est que on n'est
pas capable de vous dire si un an c'est
suffisant ce qu'on est capable de vous
dire c'est qu'en trois mois à
l'exception du jour de la finale avec le
concours de l'ensemble des acteurs nous
avons rempli les obligations que nous
imposer l'uefa à savoir les différentes
lettres de garantie à savoir la capacité
de mobiliser les aéroports d'orly de
charles de gaulle avec une capacité à
voler de nuit ce qui normalement
n'existe pas nous avons également obtenu
différents accords pour permettre le
transport des supporters à travers
différents bus et autocars nous avons
obtenu les accords notamment de la ville
de saint denis de plaine commune sur la
capacité à mobiliser des parkings aux
abords du stade de france vous donne un
élément de comparaison une pariant de la
finale de coupe de france avec 2 public
de supporters parmi les vingt mille ça a
généré 180 autobus sur cette finale de
coupe de france sur la finale de
championnat nous en avions 450 c'est pas
le même événement ce que nous avons
également réussi à construire en trois
mois c'est un dispostif d'organisation
générale qui a fonctionné ce qu'il a
manqué pour répondre précisément à votre
question c'est du temps pour préparer
l'imprévu si la manifestation est allée
à son terme c'est parce qu'en partie
nous avons rempli nos obligations et que
nous avons eu la capacité collective à
faire en sorte que le stade de france
accueille soixante quinze mille
personnes et pas plus il ya un moment où
nous en tant que fédération française de
football si nous avions eu des portes
enfoncées comme ça pue est évoquée ce
matin qu'ils ont été repoussés nous
serions retrouvés dans l'enceinte du
stade de france avec une capacité
largement supérieure à celle autorisée
et la décision nous aurions dû prendre
c'est de ne pas autoriser la rencontre
comme ça a été évoqué ce matin par
monsieur le préfet avec des conséquences
bien plus dommageable en termes de
troubles à l'ordre public donc oui nous
avons manqué de temps pour pouvoir nous
retourner vers l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour nous assurer que la
compréhension que nous avions notamment
de la grève et du fait que le trafic
serait perturbé de façon minime homme
n'aurait pas comme conséquence
d'entraîner un des ports des flux si
nous avions eu du temps nous aurions pu
plus de temps nous aurions pu nous
retourner vers la démo pc pour nous
assurer que la façon dont nous avions
conçu un dispositif notamment auprès
filtrage est ce que nous attendions
d'eux était partagé par eux et nous
aurions la cap et de nous organiser
collectivement ce que revanche nous
n'aurions jamais pu faire c'est prévoir
et croyez en mon expérience j'ai
travaillé pendant dix ans au stade de
france et je suis plus vu depuis plus de
dix ans maintenant la fédération
française de football avoir un tel
afflux de délinquants le dispositif tel
qu'il a été prévu au stade de france
permettait d'avoir douze points de près
filtrage ses 12 points après filtrage en
fait ils viennent compléter
l'environnement du stade de france qui
depuis 98 quand j'y travaillais je
voyais des champs depuis mon bureau
maintenant il n'y a plus un champ
maintenant la donne est devenu
complètement urbaine elle est saturée
par des immeubles par des immeubles
d'habitation par des immeubles
tertiaires ce que nous avons fait avec
didier pain tocca à travers un travail
remarquable pour la manifestion se
termine c'est de mettre en place des
points de près filtrage pour rendre
l'enceinte hermétique florence prenez
l'exemple de gens qui sont introduits à
travers le sang des accréditations moi
j'ai d'autres exemples à vous montrer à
quel point cette manifestation étaient
hors normes au niveau de la délinquance
il est des gens sont passés à travers
des restaurants pour rentrer dans le
périmètre protégé les gens ont fracassé
in et une école qui était une barrière
autour du stade de france naturelles ont
cassé la grille sont rentrés à
l'intérieur de l'école ont déverrouillé
la porte pour rentrer dans le périmètre
d'accès protéger aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de paris 2024 vous avez une
passerelle 81 construite pour relier le
stade de france à la piscine olympique
c'est un chantier du baht ce chantier au
haut du mât du parvis du stade de france
vous avez 4 mètre 80 les gens sont
rentrés par effraction dans le chantier
et on fait la courte échelle pour
rentrer sur le parvis du stade de france
donc et je rejoins l'avis de notre avis
à tous est de dire on aurait pu
anticiper et prévoir la grève les faux
billets et est en capacité de répondre à
cet afflux massif de supporters si on
s'était mieux coordonnées en revanche le
sujet de la délinquance il n'aurait
jamais pu être prévu
et sur la formation des stadiers alors
parce que si je suis quand j'ai pris
alors de savoir ce que je dois faire
monsieur le président pour gérer cette
manifestation la fédération a fait elle
a fait appel à dix sociétés huit
sociétés de sûreté et deux sociétés
d'accueil 1 depuis le coville on a
beaucoup de difficulté à trouver du
personnel compétent maintenant dans le
domaine de la sûreté
ces huit sociétés donc nous ont fourni
un nombre de personnels environ 1650
personnes
les sociétés de sûreté font appel à des
personnels qui sont embauchés par par
eux-mêmes qui détiennent tous un
certificat de qualification
professionnelle délivrée par le cnoss
donc tous les personnels employés pour
la partie sûreté dispose d'un certificat
de qualification professionnelle ensuite
il ya des formations au matériel sur le
terrain ces sociétés sont avec nous
maintenant depuis trois ans sont en
contrat avec la fédération depuis trois
ans donc ils connaissent parfaitement le
matériel mis à disposition au stade de
france
la particularité de cet événement
c'était la mise en place d'un contrôle
de billet en amont du prêt filtrage
comme comme l'a dit florence tout à
l'heure avec soin le contrôle du billet
papier avec un stylo chimiques ou la
deuxième chose le billy le contrôle du
téléphone avec on active est donc le
billet avec une carte électronique
beacon en appelait ça qui active le
billet qui changent la couleur du
téléphone et permet de donner un
code-barres
donc toutes les touts les personnes
concernant cette nouvelle fonction ont
été formés par lui et vallet responsable
de la billetterie à chaque poste donc
une une formation spécifique a été fait
pour cet événement
avant de vous donner la parole moi je
voudrais juste posé deux questions pour
que ce soit bien clair dans notre esprit
déjà merci de la clarté de vos propos
jusqu'à présent
on parlait beaucoup de du délai très
court des difficultés de d'anticipation
de préparation on comprend bien pour
être concret il ya eu deux réunions
organisées par la préfecture de police
juste avant l'événement terre le 25 et
le 27 mai sous la présidence du préfet
de police est ce que vous y étiez est ce
que toutes les parties prenantes et
notamment celles que vous avez cités
ratp sncf étaient également présentes
est-ce que les l'impact de la grève avec
tout les effets que vous avez décrit
fort bien sûr les flux et la complexité
que ça entraîne pour les organisateurs
est-ce que ça a été étudiée à ce moment
là est-ce que ce dialogue nécessaire
entre ceux qui transportent et ceux qui
organisent a eu lieu lors de ces
réunions du 25 et 27 alors que le
préavis de grève étaient déposés et
dernière question enfin avant dernière
question
le 27 en tout cas été connue la note de
la division de lutte contre le
hooliganisme est ce que vous vous en
avez eu connaissance qui décrivait assez
bien finalement ce qui allait se passer
est-ce que vous en avez eu connaissance
et est-ce que ça a été débattue lors de
cette réunion du 27 et enfin dernière
question il paraîtrait là on se souvient
que pour france inter baggio la
fédération française avait demandé de
déporter le match au parc des princes
est ce que vous avez fait une demande
similaire non pas de déportés parce que
c'était pas possible au parc des princes
le match 2 de la finale des signes mais
de reporter la match de la championne
singh compte tenu des risques que
nous anticipions
on n'est pas tout à fait en phase sur
les dates du 25 et 27 mai vu le nombre
de réunions que nous avons fait
nous avons une ou des réunions le 23 et
le 25 donc je pense qu'il ya mais on est
à peu près sûr les en tout cas les
thématiques que vous évoquez sont les
mêmes wheeler notamment lors de la
réunion du 23 le plan de mobilité qu'on
vous a présenté a été soumis et validé
par l'ensemble des parties prenantes en
ce inclus le fait de dire que s'il y
avait un mouvement de grève nous
demandions le fait de pouvoir déporter
les flux du rer je vais finir par y
arriver du rer b vers le vert le r du
erreurs des pères le rer b merci
c'est ce que nous avions nous avions
demandé et c'est ce qui a été fait à
partir du moment où les problèmes ont
été constatés ce qui pour nous autres ce
qui pour nous était trop tard
s'agissant de des mouvements de grève
vous avez notamment le 26 c'est à dire
deux jours avant la manifestation un
communiqué de presse de la ratp qui
informe de ce que va être le mouvement
de grève est donc comme le disait
florence qui annonce que jusqu'à 17
heures vous aurez 4 trains sur 5 et qu'à
partir de 17 heures vous aurez 5 trains
sur 7 donc nous avions également
communiquer les informations à la ratp
qui a validé auprès nous le dispositif
mis en place en leur disant danseuse
dans ce cadre de ce mouvement de grève
la qui ne nous apparaît pas comme il a
été le cas sur le dernier match vendredi
ce même mouvement de grève a été
reconduit alors faites en sorte de
continuer à mettre en place que nous
avons fait de proposer validé sur le
fait de communiquer auprès des
supporters de liverpool date de prendre
massivement le rer b et après sur le
votre point sur la note de la ldd nlh
pardon notre réponse avec très simple
c'est non nous n'avons pas été au
courant de cette note
non
nous avons des réunions le 23 à 25 après
jeu
en trois mois jeu en préparant cette
audition j'ai recompter nous n'avons
fait plus de 130 réunion avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes donc je pense que
les réunions auxquelles vous faites
référence pour nous sont le 23 et 25 et
non le 25 et le 27 mai les dates nous
ont été données par le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est là que ça je veux
alors on va passer aux questions
commençons par michel savin
merci monsieur le président madame la
direction générale monsieur le vice
président messieurs directeur tout
d'abord messieurs les présidents
permettez-moi d'abord de remercier je le
vice-président
diallo et madame la directrice générale
d'avoir présenté des excuses et
d'exprimer leur regret leur tristesse
auprès des supporters anglais qui ont
été victimes d'actes d'individus qui se
comportent comme des délinquants je
reprends vos propos donc comme la
médiatrice et messieurs merci au mois
déjà d'avoir reconnu et a présenté des
excuses à ceux qui ont été les premières
victimes de cette soirée
alors sur au niveau des questions madame
la directrice vous venez de préciser une
nouvelle fois qu'il y avait cent dix
mille personnes aux abords du stade le
soir du match
c'est un chiffre qui nous qui nous
interpellent et que nous pose chaque
fois depuis le début des auditions en
question ce matin monsieur le préfet a
été assez flou dans sa réponse est que
les 35 à 40 mille personnes pour arriver
aux 70 80 mille personnes étaient plus
proximité du stade et dans les environs
du stade
à ce qu'une photo qui a été prise par
tf1 à
21h58 donc deux minutes avant le début
du match officiel des mondes qui avait
pas trente mille quarante mille
personnes à l'extérieur du stade et ses
trente à quarante mille personnes
c'est important parce que c'est sur quoi
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est basé
pour expliquer qu'ils étaient la raison
principale les événements qui se sont
déroulés par la suite donc s'il n'était
pas là on peut se poser que sont les
origines de ces des événements qui se
sont déroulés donc
je voulais bien avoir la position la
fédération parce que vous avez fait
trois jours après les événements un
communiqué de presse qui rappellent
qu'ils avaient les cent dix mille
personnes qui s'étaient rendues au stade
de france donc encore une fois à vous
aussi la question d'où sont passés les
35 à 40 mille personnes monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur nous expliquent
qu'ils sont à proximité aux portes du
stade qui sont la cause des incidents
sur le préfet ce matin nous expliquent
qu'ils sont plutôt dans les environs
qui ne sont pas été aperçus parce qu'on
voit bien sur les images qui sont pas à
proximité du stade donc je vais bien
voir votre version dernière question
vous avez évoqué le sur le directeur
votre souhait de co construction
pensez vous que le préfet du 93 qui
connaît bien le terrain et notamment sur
l'aspect de la délinquance dans ce
département ne devrait-il pas avoir une
place beaucoup plus importante parce
qu'elle a été très peu cités dans les
réunions on va bien que ce préfet de
police qui pilote l'ensemble des
opérations est ce que le préfet du 93
devrait avoir dans l'avenir une place
plus importante dans le cadre de la
préparation de ce type de rencontre et
puis
enfin une dernière sur l'organisation et
je reprends les propos des deux
présidents on a bien compris que la
période de trois mois 18 mois c'était
compliqué
on a entendu aussi que le prix de la
république avait poussé fort pour que la
france accueille cette opération est ce
que vous avez été associé en amont à la
décision d'accueillir cette finale à
paris
je vous rappelle qu'à 16 heures on doit
prendre la vision avec le
le maire de liverpool donc on va essayer
d'être efficace je vais donner la parole
bien sûr nous avons bien sûr à chacun
donc après michel savin jean jacques
lozach et stéphane pieds noirs
bien merci puis après monsieur le
président mais messieurs les présidents
madame messieurs les représentants de la
fédération française de football
tout d'abord une question sur les
effectifs déployés sont les moyens qui
ont été mobilisés en ce qui concerne les
forces de l'ordre bon bien évidemment le
ministre de l'intérieur lui-même dit que
ces moyens étaient très très largement
suffisant il a même confirmé sa dent
dans la quotidien national du côté de la
préfecture de police je dirais que
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était un peu flou
jeantet savoir quelle est la perception
de la fédération française de football
sur
la ccl effectif quand étaient déployés
ce qui était suffisant ou pas pour ce
type de rencontre à risque deuxièmement
je vais pas revenir sur la bataille des
chiffres mais dans un communiqué de la
fédération qui remonte donc au 1er juin
dernier vous avez rappelé cette
estimation à 115 mille le nombre de
personnes se trouvant dans le périmètre
de sécurité du stade de france vous avez
évoqué comme sources de ces chiffres je
cite des opérateurs publics et privés
donc aujourd'hui est ce que vous
confirmez que c'était uniquement ce que
vous avez exprimées tout à l'heure c'est
à dire les organismes de transport ratp
sncf et taxis privés en particulier
alors sur mon jeu parvenir vêtements sur
cette fameuse note de la dnlh du 25 mai
on est encore un peu dans le flou quand
même parce que entre ceux qui ont été
destinataires de la note et qu'ils ont
lu ce qu'ils ont été destinataires mais
qu'ils l'ont pas lu ce qu'ils n'ont pas
été destinataire du tout donc j'ai
l'impression que on est encore un petit
peu dans le flou cela étant
je voudrais savoir si la fédération et
propriétaire des images qui sont captés
par la vidéo surveillance à l'intérieur
du stade de france et si oui des
éléments vidéos ont ils été transmis et
des autorités qui en aurait fait la
demande je pense notamment aux services
du ministère de l'intérieur et enfin
alors d'abord sur la question du
dédommagement des 2700 supporters
titulaires de billets mais qui n'ont pas
pu entrer dans le stade de france j'ai
entendu l'uefa s'exprimer là dessus la
fédération française va t'il être fatal
être sollicités ou pas et puis chemine à
part par une remarque mais une remarque
qui peut appeler des observations de
votre part parce qu'il va y avoir quand
même des arbitrages à venir c'est à dire
que d'un côté on a un préfet qui nous
dit que les doctrines et bien bien été
appliqué et ne saurait être remise en
question voire réactualisé et tout à
l'heure madame la directrice notamment à
présenter tout un ensemble de
préconisations tout un ensemble de
propositions qu'il serait bon d'intégrer
dans une stratégie sécuritaire
concernant des événements de ce type
stéphane thidet
si monsieur le président madame
messieurs les représentants la
fédération ce qu'on nous demande d'être
efficace je vais m'en tenir à une
question qui porte exclusivement sur les
prérogatives les missions de la
fédération française de l'organisation
de ce match est en fait ma question
porte sur la proportionnalité des
mesures qui ont été déployés concernant
le nombre de stades et il a été fait
référence vous l'avez fait dans votre
propos liminaire le
mise de l'intérieur également l'a fait
en comparant la finale de la ligue des
champions avec la finale aller de la
coupe de france nantes nice organisé
dans ce même stade quelques semaines
plus tôt et l'argumentation c'est de
dire que cette finale de coupe de france
était classée 4 sur 5 sur le risque
j'ai une question sur d'abord qui fait
ce classement est il pris en compte dans
ce classement de comment dire
l'attractivité d'une rencontre je n'ai
rien contre les supporters et ni les
clubs de nantes et de nice mais il me
semble que c'est un événement qui
revient de manière beaucoup plus
récurrente c'est à dire tous les ans et
est que une finale de ligue des
champions sur le sol français c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus rares
avec une une exposition médiatique
beaucoup plus importante qui amène
d'ailleurs un flux de circulation autour
du stade plus importante avec des
étrangers notamment qui sont par nature
moins habitués à nos moyens de
communication dont vous avez évoqué tous
les moyens qui étaient développées dans
les stations de métro de rer mais qui
sont l'obstacle de la langue peut être
levé par certains sur certaines de
certaines façons mais quand même moins
eu moins à l'aise avec ses moyens de
communiquer d'une communication dans nos
en termes de mobilité donc voilà il me
semble que vous avez des 17% de stadiers
en plus est-ce que compte tenu de tous
ces éléments
c'était suffisant parce qu'on est là
aussi pour trouver des pour se projeter
pour se dire que sans doute que cet
événement ne se reproduira pas de si tôt
on l'espère en tout cas pas dans ces
conditions-là mais trois mois de
préparation au lieu de 18 mois ça doit
quand même alerté de se dire mettons le
paquet si j'ose dire pour faire en sorte
que de faire face à l'imprévu il ya
quelqu'un qui a parlé de ça tout à
l'heure et pour faire face à l'imprévu
rien de mieux que du contrôle physique
du contrôle de sept à dix on a parlé de
la formation mais le nombre les
effectifs me regarde et me semble plutôt
plutôt insuffisant est-ce que donc avec
tous les paramètres que que je vous ai
donné vous considérez que vous avez été
un tout petit peu faiblard là dessus sur
7 sur l'effectif du nombre sur le nombre
de stadiers merci cette série de
questions y aura quatre autres
revenant par la suite
je vais essayer de répondre sur je vais
répondre notamment la question du
sénateur savador lozach sur le les flux
de spectateurs
nous avons pour habitude est assez
précis
aujourd'hui ce que nous pouvons vous
dire c'est ce que nous maîtrisons ce que
nous maîtrisons parfaitement aujourd'hui
ce sont les flux des bus puisque comme
je voulais comme je voulais exprimer
nous avons fait en sorte de d'acheminer
450 bus avec les supporters de madrid
les supporters de liverpool et
l'ensemble des populations invitées nous
avons maîtrisé également l'ensemble des
véhicules légers qui sont anne qu'ils
ont été amenés à se stationner dans les
parkings du stade de france et
s'agissant des flux et de la provenance
des transports en commun les chiffres
que nous nous donnons sont ceux qui nous
ont été communiqués par la ratp le soir
du match à savoir 6200 pour le b 36
milles pour le dé et 30 et demi pour la
ligne 13 cet ensemble là monsieur le
sénateur ça va ça représente 110 mille
personnes
ça représente 110 mille personnes qui
ont été acheminés au stade de france
nous ne sommes bien incapable de vous
dire que sont devenus ces 110 mille
personnes à part vous dire que pour 72
mille d'entre elles elles sont rentrées
au stade de france elles ont assisté à
la rencontre les 35000 au dont nous
parlons nous sommes en capacité de vous
dire qu'il y en à 2583 qui ne sont
arrivées jusqu'aux grilles du stade de
france et qui ont été refoulés parce que
leurs titres d'accès était un faux nous
sommes également qu'à passer à vous dire
que de par ce qui a été fait par les
services de l'uefa sur les pointes
préfiltre âge par les équipes de
sécurité de didier pain tôt nous avons
récupéré environ 300 faux billets qui
skie ce qui est après ce que nous
pouvons également vous dire c'est que
comme on vous l'a présenté sur la carte
du stade de france l'amplitude ce n'est
pas uniquement le parvis et sa proximité
immédiate avec les 18 portes d'accès au
sein du stade de france la zone entre
guillemets de jeu du stade de france
elle va depuis les rer jusqu'au stade de
france depuis la ligne 13 jusqu'au stade
de france qui vous donne un périmètre
extrêmement large et pour vous répondre
précisément à votre question nous avons
la même que vous monsieur le sénateur et
la personne donc à l'entité qui doit
vous répondre qui peut vous apporter les
éléments de réponse c'est la ratp sur le
sa capacité d'emport est le nombre de
trains qui à partir de 17h sont repartis
vers le centre de paris ouvert les
aéroports avec un flux de spectateurs
supérieur à celui qui est d'habituer
lmnp constaté à même jour sur une
semaine précédente
et pour vous donner des éléments
d'appréciation en tout cas tel que tel
que nous n va était remonté certaines
personnes de la ratp nous ont confirmé
qu à partir de 21h le flux était
suffisamment important pour qu'ils
rajoutent des trains en allant vers
paris et ça pour nous c'est un élément
d'appréciation important je vais
également vous répondre sur le sujet de
la co construction et le rôle de la
préfecture du 93 du préfet bitos qui est
son directeur de cabinet frédéric
loiseau
ils nous ont apporté une aide
considérable
c'est eux qui nous ont poussés dans nos
retranchements sur le plan de mobilité
ceux qui nous ont alertés sur un
ensemble de risques il fallait qu'il
fallait prendre en compte et oui je vous
rejoins même si nous ne sommes pas ceux
qui font les lois et l'organisation de
la sécurité en france sur le rôle de la
préfecture de police et sa compétence
sur les territoires sur les départements
limitrophes mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que lauren a été essentiel
dans la construction de cet événement et
oui je vous rejoins sur le fait que
demain si cela est possible dans un
cadre législatif
appartement où il c'est valable pour la
préfecture du 93 comme pour d'autres
préfectures sur des événements qui se
déroulerait dans d'autres territoires la
connaissance du terrain était et est
essentielle la connaissance de ces ce
qui se passe dans chacune des soirées et
des nuits dans le 93 est tel que nous le
dit préfet vitaux ce qui manifestement
les nuits sont agitées pour ne pas dire
autre chose oui c'est quelque chose
d'important à prendre en compte dans la
construction dans la construction d'un
événement
concernant le dimensionnement du
dispositif entre la coupe de france et
donc la finale de la cup le cliq 2
manifestation totalement différente
la finale de la coupe de france classée
niveau 4 pourquoi il y avait il ya des
grands risques d'affrontement entre les
deux clubs les clubs sont connus pour
s'affronter à toutes les rencontres
quand il se voit en championnat de plus
on avait les informations comme quoi des
supporters parisiens venait se mêler à
cette à ces deux clubs pour s'affronter
également donc il y avait classé niveau
4 parce qu'il y avait un risque élevé de
troubles à l'ordre public à l'extérieur
du stade de france
concernant la finale de la champion's
league
le risque était totalement différent on
avait la formation quand pour les faux
billets on n'avait pas de nombre mais on
savait que les supporters anglais
avaient l'habitude de venir avec des
faux billets dont le dispositif à
dimanche a été dimensionné d'une façon
plus élevés pour justement pallier à
cette à ce risque notamment on a ouvert
beaucoup plus de points de préfet trash
on en ouvre 8 habituellement là en
allant vers 12 on a donc multiplié le
nombre de personnels on a aussi augmenté
on appelle ça des équipes d'intervention
des personnels mobiles à l'intérieur du
site dans le stade qui sont prêts à
intervenir à tout endroit pour
intervenir sur des troubles ça on est
passé d'un nombre de 40 à 112 112 agents
vous dire si j'ai bien dimensionner le
dispositif témoin même qu'il est
dimensionné je tends sur vous dire oui
après la manifestation j'ai tendance à
vous dire non j'aurais dû encore
augmenter les effectifs est ce que sera
changé quelque chose dans du patient
parce que le problème principal c'est
quand même la présence important à des
pointes très filtrage de personnes avec
faux billets ou sans faux billets qui
bloquaient les points de filtrage et
rendait l'accès des spectateurs avec vie
est impossible
je voudrais juste le groupe par rapport
à ce que vous disiez didier vous
préciser quelque chose par rapport à ce
que nous avons identifiées sur le faux
billets
ce que ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir sur
les événements tel que l'évoqué florent
sur des sons des grands concerts ou des
grandes manifestations c'est des gens
qui achètent qui ont le sentiment
d'acheter un vrai faux billets en le
payant une somme très élevée par rapport
à la valeur faciale de ce billet mais il
2000 3000 4000 cinq 4000 ou 5000 euros
un billet qui en vaut 100 200 300 400
ce dont nous nous sommes rendu compte
depuis la finale de champion's league
c'est qu'il ya eu un trafic de faux
billets mais vendu de façon sciemment
auprès de gens qu'il le savait alors
qu'il ya notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux et nous avons transmis tous les
éléments au préfet cannes dans la note 4
fournit la fédération française de
football vous avez des gens qui ont
vendu des billets 50 livres dire moins
cher que la valeur faciale du billet en
expliquant très précisément aux gens qui
allaient acheter ses billets là qu'ils
avaient la possibilité de pattes peuvent
potentiellement passé le pré filtrage
en présentant ce faux billets en faisant
pression sur nos agents mais qu'il n'y
avait aucune chance pour eux de rentrer
dans le stade de france et que c'était à
eux de se débrouiller à ce moment là
pour entrer dans l'enceinte et c'est
pour ça que le chiffre est élevé de 2583
billets que nous avons intercepté aux
portes du stade de france mais ce qui
est important de comptes d'avoir en tête
c'est que le nombre de personnes qui
sont venues au stade de france sachant
pertinemment qu'elle avait un faux
billets et que la seule possibilité pour
elles de rentrer dans le stade de france
était trouver le moment opportun où les
portes à les céder ou le barriérage
allait être enfoncé et à ce moment là se
précipite dans l'enceinte était bien
plus important que la personne qui de
bonne foi pensaient avoir acheté un vrai
billet légend apporte un élément de
réponse par rapport à la question du
sénateur lozach sur la vidéosurveillance
les images sont disponibles pendant 7
jours au bout de sept jours elles sont
automatiquement détruites et la seule
façon c'est qu'on aurait dû avoir une
réquisition pour les fournir aux
différentes populations en revanche que
je peux vous livrer c'est le sentiment
que didier moi même avons eu en étant
que ces sécurités toute la journée les
images sont extrêmement violentes
réquisitions qui n'a pas eu lieu alors
que la justice a été saisie dès le
samedi soir
la justice a été saisie pour sur la base
de l'article 40 sur la foule à la fosse
billetterie
concernant la question du classement de
deux niveaux de risque des rencontres et
bien la division nationale de lutte
contre l'organisme qui propose à
monsieur le préfet le classement de la
rencontre
merci monsieur assouline pour deux
minutes ensuite madame lesage brillant
ce qui est ce qui est dommage parce que
j'avais prévu des questions précises
mais d'un coup je veux relever que ce
qui vient d'être dit est très important
voire grave
car
et j'aurais bien aimé que le préfet soit
auditionné après vous ça veut dire que
des images vous jugé très violente
existait et qu'il n'y a pas eu de la
part de l'autorité
notamment la préfecture oui on aurait pu
avoir d'autres mais il ya bien eu une
réquisition au titre de l'article 40 ils
ont été détruites c'est ce qui vient
d'être dit n'a pas été fait dans les
délais de sept jours et donc c'est
détruits
donc il y a des preuves qui ont été
détruits par
on va dire au moins compétents ce que
j'ai pas envie de penser en plus que
c'est fait exprès ne pas l'avoir fait
donc ça c'est très grave moi je trouve
que c'est très grave c'est une
responsabilité très important de
l'autorité publique deuxième question
c'est sur la compréhension des choses
n'est pas compris sur le pré filtrage on
nous a dit le ministre on est amusé
beaucoup ça nous a été redit ce matin
que à un moment donné vous puisque c'est
vous qui avez cette capacité de dans le
pré filtre avec un stylo qui etc il y
avait des stadiers dont qui se
retournait ma mère les forces de l'ordre
qui disait il ya 90% de
deux taux de faux billets où tous les
cas d' de panne en tous les cas ils ont
jugé que c'était une panne du stylo est
ce que ça vous est revenu parce que
voilà donc
ça c'était ma deuxième question des
précisions là dessus je je je vous pose
une question prospectifs pour l'avenir
je les dis ce matin parce que ça c'est
vraiment de votre compétence en vain
c'est celle de l'uefa mais vous avez un
rôle important à jouer auprès d'eux
ne pensez-vous pas que quand il ya des
manifestations populaires de ce type
avec l'engouement qu'elle suscite et je
dis bien populaire c'est à dire que
c'est pas l'opéra de paris
c'est
un public qui est populaire qu'on incite
à consommer du football toute la journée
aussi ea ya ce match et il y a
vingt-huit mille
billets vip
7000 au grand public et 20000 à chaque
club ce que vous pensez pas que
structurellement 7 se dispatchent âge
créer un problème après aux forces de
l'ordre de l'assumer mais ça crée un
problème
j'ai je finis moi j'ai été à une finale
de ligue des champions dans ma vie
c'était arsenal barcelone au stade de
france
j'étais effaré voir déjà avec pénurie ou
à dire des
gens vraiment simple
de conditions
défavorisés
avoir dans leurs poches des centaines
voire des milliers d'euros en liquide
pour acheter une place les certainement
des anglais d'un supporteur d'arsenal
qui étaient prêts à mettre leur paye
pour cela
est ce que vous pensez pas que quand on
crée un tel une telle situation au
niveau pécunier au niveau argent
après on peut dire il ya des délinquants
qu'ils viennent et où on peut quand même
considérer que dans la famille entre
guillemets eu des des pickpockets c'est
bien d'être là ce soir là et pas de son
d'être ailleurs parce que là il ya des
milliers d'euros en liquide dans les
poches de gens qui circulent tout seul
ou en famille etc bon voilà donc je veux
juste finir ça c'est c'est une question
parce que pour les jeux olympiques et
d'autres ça les autorités sportives le
verrons le fait que les billets soient
abordables pour que vraiment les gens
puissent venir et que on ne crée pas une
situation de rareté tels que ça produit
aussi de la délinquance merci madame
eustache brinio pour deux minutes oui
merci monsieur l'avalanche de la gontrie
essayé de tenir en deux minutes et c'est
merci la parole deux mots d'abord je
voulais d'abord vous remercier madame et
messieurs de la fédération pour la
transparence et la clarté de grand popo
et et en particulier sur quelque chose
qui me tient à coeur c'est de ne pas
être dans le déni de ce qui s'est passé
donc sur la billetterie je n'y
reviendrai pas mais en particulier sur
les problèmes de délinquance qui ont eu
lieu ce soir là qu'ils ont quand même
provoqué voilà la stupeur d'un bon
nombre de deux français mais pas que
deux français et moi ce que je regrette
c'est que depuis la depuis ce match
depuis que le real madrid a gagné on n'a
pas parlé de la victoire on ne parle que
de preuves de sécurité que de violence
et ce match ne laissera dans l'histoire
que ça c'est quand même dommage parce
qu'on ne parle pas de la victoire du
real de madrid et du beau match de
liverpool donc c'est aussi une
responsabilité collective que nous avons
de dire ça donc merci pour leur peau
madame la dyarchie j'espère que ne
seront pas traités de nauséabond comme
moi les miens ont pu être traitées par
le ministre de l'intérieur lorsque j'ai
parlé du problème de délinquance en
début de semaine donc merci pâte pour
tout cela moi je vais savoir deux choses
d'abord je vais savoir à partie moment
où le président la république avait
décidé en gros que ce match avait lieu à
paris est ce que sous l'égide du
ministre des sports ou d'humidité
intérieur une espèce de réunion un peu
d'urgence a été organisée au sein de ces
deux ministères avec j'ai envie de dire
tous les partenaires pour ce que
j'appellerais mobiliser les troupes en
disant oui on vous impose ça en trois
mois alors on va peut-être tout se
mettre autour de la table pour faire en
sorte que ce soit une belle fête du foot
est-ce que moi il ya eu une réunion avec
tout le monde
et sinon est-ce que vous pensez que ça
aurait pas été utile et puis je savoir
exactement combien il ya eu deux
réunions avec
tous les partenaires autour de la table
c'est à dire vous effectivement qu'ils
avaient une délégation de l'uefa mais
les la ratp la sncf le stade de france
les entreprises concernées est ce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de réunions avec tous ses
partenaires ensemble de manière à
anticiper tout ce qui n'a pas ce qu'on a
vu dysfonctionné ce jour là et puis
juste une toute petite dernière question
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure à
l'instant là qu'un certain nombre de
personnes avait des faux billets il
était de bonne foi et que d'autres
avaient les faux billets et qui le
savait comment avec comment pouvez-vous
nous donner ce chiffre et quels éléments
vous avez pour me dire certaines avaient
des faux billets de bonne foi et de
bonne foi comment vous avez pu estimer
ce chiffre merci madame de la gontrie et
puis monsieur grosperrin merci d'en
ligne merci président comme le temps
nous est compté
3 3 questions la première vous avez
détaillé tout à l'heure la fréquentation
des différentes lignes de transport 13
rer b rer b et vous avez
pointé et regretter à la fois le
basculement de des usagers qui passaient
du bo d et la carence d'informations sur
ce point qui est peut-être justifie
d'ailleurs la disproportion de stadiers
puisque paradoxalement vous aviez
beaucoup plus de stadiers à l'arrivée du
bébé qu aux autres mais à quelque chose
qui m'intrigue lorsque vous dites ça
puisque vous pointez coordination
circulation d'informations c'est que en
vous écoutant je regardais sur internet
mais la grève était annoncée deux jours
plus tôt il y avait des messages rer b
10 ans ne prenez pas le rer b prenez le
d et c alors moi je j'entends le
problème de coordination de circulation
d'informations et je pense que c'est
réel mais n'empêche que n'est pas bien
quand vous informe de cela je veux dire
que c'était de notoriété publique donc
c'est là que c'est un petit peu étrange
deuxième chose vous avez indiqué donc
vous aviez eu trois mois ça on le sait
pour organiser cette cette finale là où
d'habitude c'était 18 mois alors je sais
pas s'il faut 18 mois d'habitude mais
est-ce que selon vous il était possible
d'organiser
de manière satisfaisante
cette manifestation en trois mois ou
est-ce que l'accident était prévisible
et la troisième question c'est que
depuis que nous faisons des auditions
moi je n'ai toujours pas extrêmement
bien compris qui pilotait l'ensemble de
l'opération c'est à dire qu'il ya
délégation interministérielle
que nous n'avons pas encore auditionné
mais je sais que c'est prévu le préfet
de police qui ce matin nous a expliqué
qu'il était responsable et comptable de
tous etc etc mais au final
qui qui était pilote et là c'est votre
vécu que j'interroge qui était pilote
qui décident est parce que au fond
peut-être que c'était ça le problème
c'est que les choses étaient voilà donc
c'était ma troisième question de la
sénatrice est ce que monsieur grosperrin
est en ligne
car s'il ne l'est pas je donnerai tout
de suite la parole à paroles oui oui
président je suis en ligne très bien
nous vous écoutons oui merci a vous de
me donner la parole merci président
messieurs et mesdames et messieurs la
fédération moi je suis dans la même
ligne que prisa la faune lorsqu'il parle
de propos contradictoires voire de deux
zones d'ombré la première question c'est
est-ce que lors de nombreux rayons nous
a montré du kavé de ris beaucoup de
rayons est ce que vous avez prévenu
alerté la préfecture de police le plus
haut niveau de l'état sur les risques de
ce match dans la mesure aussi que les
baies repoussé dépassent en nombre son
billet est souvent sont dans des
systèmes d'infraction la deuxième
question est ce que le fait qu'il n'y
ait des billets qu'ils soient des
billets support papier donc on ne
pouvait imaginer ce qui pouvait se
passer est-ce que vous la fédération
vous aviez la possibilité sous couvert
de l'uefa 2 d'interdire ou de ne pas de
ne pas faire ce type de manifestation et
enfin le préfet ce matin me disais nous
disait pardon ce n'était pas un match à
risque or début de vos interventions le
vice-président diallo a dit qu'il avait
reçu une note comme quoi c'est un match
triste de 4,5 est ce qu il faisait
référence à l'âme à la note sur nantes
sur le match de nantes où est ce qu il a
fait référence également sur sur l'eau
de la préfecture qu'il aurait reçus à
ces niveaux là pour ce match là merci
merci micro peur monsieur grosperrin moi
j'ai une
dernière question avant de vous laisser
la parole main messieurs tout à l'heure
la question était posée par je ne sais
pas quel collègues pour savoir si le
prix à la république avant d'insister et
de recevoir cette finale à paris vous
avez consulté sur la capacité à faire
merci vous avez la parole ah pardon
monsieur la fin donc juste une précision
plus qu'une question mais à quel moment
vous entendiez apprécié de m demande de
précision à quel moment avez vous eu les
chiffres par la ratp la sncf sur les
flux de voyageurs est ce que c'est bell
samedi soir où ces quelques jours plus
tard en temps réel le samedi soir
je n'ai pas qu'il souhaite s'exprimer
sur la série de questions du président
monsieur
je vais répartir des stylos allez-y pour
la partie stylo officiel donc
effectivement sur chaque point de presse
filtrage on a un responsable et le soir
de la manifestation effectivement un
responsable du contrôle des billets nous
a appelés à la radio pour nous demander
de faire réintégrer des nouveaux silos
puisque ça ne fonctionnait plus
nous avons donc détaché le responsable
billetterie de l'uefa sur le lieu
le constat est les stylos fonctionne
très bien il s'agit de faux billets en
fait
oui tous les stylos fonctionner très
bien mais ne prenez pas la modification
de la couleur sur le billet
donc il s'agissait en fait de mauvais
biais de faux billets c'est pour ça
qu'en fait les stadiers croyait que les
stylos ne fonctionnait plus
sur ce point de près filtrage sur ce
point de près filtrage précis ça ne faut
que c'était des faux billets
juste pour préciser parce que ce que
disait didier pinteaux l'uefa nous a
fourni des stylos 9 nous avons avec
l'ensemble des personnels de l'uefa et
les personnels de de la sécurité tester
le matin ces silos qui marchait
parfaitement un stylo qui marche ça veut
dire qu'au dos du billet vous avez un
encadré vous passez le stylo cet encadré
devient rose si cet encadré ne modifie
pas sa couleur reste blanc le bia est
faux ce qui nous a été remontée dès 17h
au pc de sécurité nourriture et didier
pain tôt c'est que les stadiers nous
remonter les chefs d'equipe en dix ans
nous avons appris avec vos stylos il ne
marche pas parce que il n'en prime pas
la couleur rose sur les billets nous
avons alerté l'uefa qui a envoyé une
équipe sur les différents points de près
filtrage avec de nouveaux stylos qui a
pris dix billets par point de près
filtrage et en moyenne sur ces dites sur
ces dix billets entre 4 et 7 et fo voilà
où ça qu'ils se sont rendu compte des
exactement d'accord exactement
la question qui me vient à l'esprit
à partir de quelle heure
si oui j'ai pas terminée à partir de
quelle heure le stade est ouvert au
public pour qu'ils prennent place à
l'intérieur
alors vous avez deux de niveau de prise
en compte le premier prix la prise en
compte c'est l'activation du prêt
filtrage qui était prévu à midi et qui a
été activée à 11h50 et la deuxième la
deuxième motion c'est l'ouverture des
portes du stade de france qui a été
prévu à 18h et qui a ouvert à 18 heures
d'accord
il présenta un public qui vous a
consulté ou pas la réponse est non je
vais voilà qu'est ce qu'il y avait une
question il ya d'autres questions il
faut apprendre aux questions
de minutes avant de cueillir le maire de
givet liverpool je vais vous apporter
les réponses sur le
le sujet de l'organisation générale
la décision a été prise le 28 février le
4 mars nous avions la première réunion
de coordination
organisée par l'adie geste la ddjs le
préfet le préfet cadot voilà qui a
regroupé l'ensemble des acteurs et des
parties prenantes
en moyenne nous avions on va dire
environ une réunion par semaine dans
différentes thématiques thématique
transport thématique fan zone avec les
villes de paris et de saint denis
thématique sécurité avec la préfecture
de police à chacune de ses réunions nous
avions les équipes du préfet cadot qui
était présente donc la coordination
générale de l'événement elle s'est fait
sous l'égide du délégué interministériel
et ses équipes à chacune de ses réunions
les équipes de l'adie ges étaient
présentés les comptes rendus été
produits ça a permis de construire
l'événement et il faut le reconnaître
même s'il a faim n'est pas celle que
nous attendions ça a permis de les
acteurs on ne sont jamais autant
mobilisé à nos côtés de par le délai
contraint que pour mettre faire preuve
de bonne volonté et abattre un prêt les
uns les écueils que nous rencontrions
pour la délimitation ce qu'il faut avoir
bien
micro niveau de la régie
[Musique]
pardon ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut avoir
également en tête c'est la particularité
de cette finale la même finale avec un
autre club que le club de liverpool vous
évoquez les uns et les autres cette
problématique connue de supporters qui
se déplacent en très grand nombre et
c'est pour ça que nous avons mis une une
pression certaine sur les villes de
paris et de saint denis pour aboutir à
avoir des fans zone qui nous ont permis
d'accueillir 44 mille personnes sur
celle de paris et 6000 à l'instant t
mais au final douze mille sur celle de
madrid sur la journée d'avant de prendre
en compte ce nombre important de
spectateurs et c'est que ce qui est pour
nous était et est également important
j'insiste la coordination qui a été fait
à mobiliser l'ensemble des services de
l'état l'ensemble des ministères se sont
mobilisés à nos côtés aux côtés de
l'uefa qui a fait avec nous toutes les
réunions qui était présente à chaque
fois pour organiser cet événement
dans ce que nous pensions être les
meilleures conditions et dans ce qui au
final est un échec pour nous tous et
c'est bien le l'enseignement que nous en
tirons nous fédération française de
football comme le disait notre vice
président et la directrice générale
c'est un sentiment de tristesse de par
l'investissement qui a été consentis par
toutes les personnes qui sont mobilisées
autour de cet événement est ce que nous
en nous que nous en attendions ce
n'était pas cette fin là et j'insiste
sur ce point là tout le travail que nous
avons fait de coordination avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
effectivement je vous rejoins il ya des
moments on aurait dû prendre le temps de
se dire est-ce que vous avez bien
compris notre demande est ce que la
réussite on vous nous en fait est la
bonne est ce que nous partageons en fait
le fait de dire que en prenant cette
décision nous assumons ce risque là où
nous faisons en sorte de ne plus avoir
ce risque là et nous nous concentrons
sur notre objectif premier qui est
d'accueillir et d'organiser la
manifestation
alors monsieur ça va mais vraiment 40
secondes c'est même pas une question
c'est pour madame la directrice
simplement un problème de communication
tout à l'heure vous avez rappelé qu'il y
avait eu des retours importants à après
21h en termes de transport quand je lis
le communiqué la sncf
rien de particulier n'a été constaté au
niveau des retours à 22h en termes
d'afflux la sncf précise qu aucun flux
particulier aux plus importants que
d'habitude n'a été enregistré dans
l'autre sens après le début du match
donc la sncf elle même dit qu'il n'y a
pas eu d'afflux de spectateurs
c'est une contradiction une de plus donc
comprenez qu'on peut se poser des
questions merci monsieur
une
savez ce que la sncf peut communiquer
ses flux sur la journée du 28 mai les
flux montants au stade de france dès les
flux descendant nous allons auditionner
la sncf monsieur assouline oui et j'ai
eu juste sûr je reviens sur l'histoire
de la destruction des images sur vous
nous avez donc informé de cela et
qui devait selon vous
il y avait des images des caméras
monsieur les a vus et dit qu'elle était
extrêmement violent c'est comme n'y a
pas eu de réquisition laisser les gens l
ont été détruites je trouve tellement
cela tellement aberrant que je vous pose
la question qui devait
agir pour qu'elles soient pas détruites
et offert la réquisition qui en avait la
principale responsable vecteurs
je voudrais juste me faire le porte
parole une fois pour une fois se sont
écrasés tout seul c'est automatique oui
d'accord secret ce sont des tragédies
n'a été que j'appelais sturm est ce que
je veux pas entendre la réponse à ma
question de votre part qui devait le
faire
il faut une réquisition judiciaire
autres donc
ccc l'avocat de bradley de police dont
ces procureur public d'accord c'est une
décision judiciaire l'acquisition des
images de vidéo protection donc c'était
au procureur public de de demander
l'acquisition de ces images en revanche
il est vrai que sur un plan pratique les
images s'écrase tout seul dans le délai
qui est imparti par la loi et tu suis
personne s'il procure on ne fait pas de
réquisition évidemment elles
disparaissent monsieur lafon oui juste
pour revenir sur un point qui est
important c'était une question de marie
pierre de la gontrie et je fais ce porte
parole pour une fois pour qu'on
comprenne bien notamment par rapport à
la problématique de la grève vous avez
connaissance du préavis de grève on a
compris que telle est la discussion avec
l'atp ne fonctionne pas de manière
opérationnelle à ce moment-là vous
laissez vos points de filtrage tels
qu'ils avaient été envisagées c'est à
dire l'essentiel des points de filtrage
côté rer b alors que vous on peut
imaginer qu'avec la grève ils y aura le
phénomène de report solaire des
finalement
final vous corrigerez si on n'a pas bien
compris mais c'est pour ça que je me
permets de ré insisté là dessus
finalement on constate le jour du match
que malgré le préavis de grève quatre
rer b sur 5 fonctionne
donc le rer b fonctionne mais que parce
qu'il ya eu les annonce préalable laisse
des spectateurs et notamment les anglais
utilisent quand même le rer d et donc il
ya un afflux sur les points de filtrage
du rer d il n'y a pas de liaison à ce
moment là je résume et vous corriger si
on a mal compris mais c'est important il
n'y a pas de raison à ce moment là entre
la ratp et vous pour dire réorientons
sur les points de filtrage c'est bien ça
mais je nous avons bien compris aussi
que quand il ya eu une annonce du
préavis de grève il ya pas une
modification de votre part sur la
répartition des points de filtrage en se
disant il y aura un phénomène de report
cela rrd il faut peut-être mettre plus
de points de filtrage sur la rd ou
prévoir un cheminement qui oriente vers
les 9 à 10 points de filtrage du rer b
je vous confirme exactement ce que vous
venez dire les différentes réunions que
nous avons menées avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes sur l'organisons des
événements et le plan de mobilité
nous ont amenés à proposer un plan de
mobilité incitant fortement les
spectateurs en faisant notamment appel à
la ratp à la sncf en achetant un
dispositif complémentaire de mobilité
pour orienter les spectateurs vers le
rer b
le jour de la manifestation donc les
dernières réunions c'est ce plan là
était présente et nous y ont notamment
dans cette réunion mots organisée
par le préfet du 93 nous avons présenté
ce plan ce plan a été validé nous
n'avons jamais eu une information à part
un communiqué de presse diffusé le 26
pour le 28 informant que il y avait une
grève mais que le trafic était pas loin
d'être optimale avec 4 1 sur 5 puis 5-3
sur ta partir de 17h et nous avons
découvert dans l'après midi du match que
finalement la ratp dans certaines
stations notamment les hubs de châtelet
donation inciter les personnes à se
rendre au stade en utilisant le rer d
merci ah
merci
le silence
vos réponses
madame monsieur le président messieurs
merci de votre venue et des éléments que
vous avez porté à la connaissance de nos
deux commissions et